[Music]
thank you all for coming out tonight my
name is Alexander rose on the executive
director here at the long now foundation
and I want to make a huge thanks to to
you Andy for I think we cornered you
into giving this talk months ago when
when Hugh Howey your friend was here and
and you wanted to come in and I was like
oh that'd be great if you could give a
talk and you agree like long before this
movie thing was really blowing up so I
know that it's now become a kink in your
schedule and I appreciate for you
holding holding true to our little thing
and and also Peter Schwartz from our
board who you know is it is is outwardly
a futurist but deep down is a rocket
scientist from way back whenever we do
space things we have to call on Peter
and we've done a few things differently
with some of you guys notice that not
only that the tickets sold out in two
minutes but the that we also have a
patron ticket level and so I want to
thank all of you patron ticket level
people it's it's since we can't have the
capacity that we wish we could have here
it allows these talks to be somewhat
viable at least reasonably so and we
have tonight the long now members are
listening in on the livestream everyone
shout out to the livestream people nice
and and we were looking for a sponsor
for our livestream from here and
amazingly one of our members and former
speakers Edward Burtynsky who if you
remember spoke for us and has done
amazing photographs of the manufactured
world and did a movie with his partner
manufactured landscapes is now working
on a movie called Anthropocene which is
going to be he's gonna be working on
over the next three years and that
production has generously now funding
all the live streaming for 2016 and it's
a perfect fit I think for long now and
it will culminate in three years from
now when he actually screens the film
here in San Francisco so it'll be a
it'll be a fun thing and with that Peter
Thank You Sandra so
it really is a serious delight for me to
be here I am a space nerd right you know
and is there anybody in this book who
has not read the room who's not read the
Martian or seen the movie and how many
how many friends of Andy are there here
and on the fanboy in this case
absolutely and this is a book at a film
that I think is one of the most
important in a very long time this is
the best piece of science fiction that I
you know if somebody's helped write
movies and written books this is
absolutely the best piece of science
fiction maybe ever done and it is really
an honor a pleasure and a delight to
have you here Andy I think it's a kind
of book that and film that will actually
change the world it will have an impact
in lots of ways we were talking about
all the ways it affecting science
education and I'm actually going to
bring up something in a little bit later
with John gage during the conversation
so let me tell you what we're gonna do
we're gonna talk a little bit about the
book and the movie at the beginning the
fans stuff and then we're actually gonna
go into what's it actually gonna take to
get to Mars and Andy's gonna talk and I
may interrupt them a bit along the way
you know I'm an astronaut achill
engineer I can't resist that and then
we're gonna open it up to a conversation
with everybody and we'll do all that in
roughly an hour that makes sense so you
know one of the really interesting
aspects of this book is how it came to
be you know you were a software engineer
working and you began this as a kind of
personal project and it became something
much more tell us how the book evolved
well I mean when I was a kid or our
teenager
III always wanted to be a writer just my
whole life I want to be a writer but I
also like eating regular meals and not
sleeping on a park bench so when the
time came to choose a profession I went
into computer programming but I so I say
but I always wanted to be a writer
so while I was in college getting
working toward my computer science and
engineering degree I also wrote a book
it sucked but that's all you know I had
the same experience that my mind was
stolen and I was so
I never have to look at it again here
where you go yeah mine this was a it was
called the observer it was dystopian it
was crappy and it it was before the era
of the internet so there's no digital
copies of it out there no one will ever
find it I know your mother hasn't my
mother does have a community you've done
your research bring it over you yeah
yeah yeah she has a copy somewhere I
don't know where I don't like if she
knows not to tell me where it is but um
so anyway I went through four years of
college and then didn't graduate because
I ran out of money because that's what
my generation does so I went straight
into the computer programming industry
because at the time it was if you could
if you could stumble into a software
company you could get a job it was like
1994 and there was a tech boom going on
and that was awesome right up until 1999
when I when the kind of the bottom fell
of the market and I got laid off from
AOL with about eight hundred and my
closest friends well I was well when
they merged with Netscape that's how
long ago that was and so I I had enough
money from a good severance package and
stock options that I that I realized
helped now's my chance I can take a shot
at being a writer I can go a few years
without having to work so I will I will
write a book so I wrote a book and then
didn't get that one published either
because that one also wasn't very good
the difference between these two books
was the first one I wrote it sucked and
I knew it the second one sucked and I
didn't know it yeah and so I put a lot
of work at heart yeah that one's hard
and so I tried to get it I tried to get
it published and after three years I
gave up and I went I went back into the
computer industry but it wasn't like a
hang your head Charlie Brown kind of
situation I like programming computers
and I'm good at it and it's fun and I
like my co-workers mostly
my former coworker one of them right
here but yeah and so I went back into
computer programming and I decided okay
for now and I'll just write as a hobby
and this newfangled internet thing is up
and I can post my stories online so I
made Comet you know like web comics and
short stories and serials and I posted
them all to my website I just kind of a
general dumping ground I should say my
son reads all that stuff this will
impress my wife who thinks that's all
craps okay there we go
I can't I can't I cannot guarantee that
it's not all crap I can't tell you that
that's what I get and so I wrote a bunch
of stories and then I post them to my
site and over like the next ten years or
so I built up a mailing list of about
3,000 people which sounds like a lot but
that's ten years you know so it's not
it's not like some truly impressive
accomplishment it's just perseverance
just I kept posting content and
gathering regular readers and I would
email out to this list whenever I posted
something new anyway I was working at
three on three serials at the time right
around 2009 one of them was one of them
was the Martian one of them was a story
of an alien invasion of Earth and one of
them was a story of a six-year-old
mermaid girl living in 19th century New
England so obviously common themes right
so all these things go together yeah
they're all gonna tie together later no
but yeah and the Martian was just one of
the things that I was writing to my site
and was a serial I didn't take it very
seriously it was just sort of a join us
next week for the further adventures of
Mark Watney oz you know it's just like
something like that and but people
really liked it and eventually I
finished and I'm like okay I'm done onto
other things but I started get email
from folks
I mean people said like oh hey I love
your I love the Martian but I hate
reading it in on a web page because your
site sucks and it did I mean it's just
ghetto it's just like white background
blue links left-justified I mean it's
just like nothing and they're like can
you make an e-reader version so I did
that I made me reader version and I
posted it on the site I'm like there you
go then I got other email from people
saying oh hey I got that there's a you
know I love your story hate your site I
see there's an e-reader version
but I'm not very technically savvy and I
don't know how to download a thing from
the internet and put it on my e-reader
can you just post it to Amazon okay so I
go to Amazon and I've figure out how to
self publish it doesn't require any
upfront cost or anything like that any
idiot can do it and you yeah you just
post your thing up there and then they
hang on to it for like 48 hours to have
a human look at it to make sure you're
not just posting a bunch of goat porn
but then don't judge but then but then
once it's once it's out there you cannot
you can't give it away that's I wanted
to give it away for free but you can't
Amazon actually makes their money from
the book sales the e-book sales they
sell Kindles at a loss so they won't let
you give content away for free app to
set the price at $0.99 so I set the
price at $0.99 and it started to sell
really well and it got a lot of really
good reviews and like more people bought
it then downloaded it for free from my
site such as the reach of Amazon into
the readership market and what year was
this so this was 2012 is when I saw
public that was in like September of
2012 by March of 2013 it was like number
one in sci-fi it was in the top hundred
of all Kindle and it was selling really
well and had like thousands of ratings
it was like four and a half stars so it
was doing doing really well and then I
got I didn't know this but at the time
there was a an editor at Random House
named Julian padilla who was recommended
the book and he's like that I don't know
if I want to read this or if it's just
engineering for now and then he was
talking to a colleague of his name David
Fugate who's a literary agent and he's
like I this thing about reading this I
don't know and David's like well I can
read it and give you my opinion and he's
like sure
so David read it and then he's like I
like it he came to me and said do you
need an agent do you need a literary
agent so after three years earlier in
life have not even be able to get
responses from literary agents I have
one knocking at my door
so I go online to make sure he's like a
real person and then
and then I'm like sure you can be my
agent and he turns around go he's like
great Julian how much you gonna pay us
for this book so so then I so they'd
started negotiating a print deal then I
got this random query directly from fox
twentieth century fox said like hey
we're interested in the film option for
the Martian I'm like talk to my agent
and so my agent said I'm gonna find this
out to a film agent so the film agents
are specialists in film contracts so
these two negotiations are going on at
the same time and so ultimately the
print deal and the film deal came
together four days apart so that was an
eventful week for me at that at that
time by the way I'm still computer
programmer so I'm in my cubicle fixing
bugs and walking off to take a call on
my movie deal then back to the cubicle
picture so it was really very strange
there's a movie in this yep and then
pretty much everyone knows the rest they
did they did make the moot you know the
book got on the New York Times
bestseller list they made the movie it
was number one it's number one right now
which is so one piece of the story
though that you didn't mention is the
engagement with your readers about the
science oh sure
when when I was writing it you know so
my I I never imagined this would have
mainstream appeal because I was writing
it for a bunch of dorks I mean it might
my readers are people are people like
well you and and I imagine that it would
just be interesting to hardcore science
geeks that III that's why there's so
much detailed math and stuff because I
knew they'd check because that's what
they're like but and and it was cool
because as I posted chapter by chapter
it took me three years to write the book
and I posted a chapter every month or
two in if I if there were any math
errors chemistry errors physics errors
electronics anything Ron they would tell
me and so I got told many times it's
like nope you got this chemistry wrong
here's how it would work oh you got this
you got this thing wrong here's here's
the realities of the situation so it was
like I had 3,000 fact checkers so it's
really cool I look I think this is fact
this is the intelligence of the commune
is greater than anyone of us and the
ability to engage with that as far as I
know no other book has done it quite
this way I don't know yeah no and I you
know as a science geek myself who read
it and with you know every chapter with
the light I was telling my wife as we
were going on wow you should see this in
how he worked this problem out and so on
as someone who actually had to solve
problems like that on Apollo you know it
was a real delight to see that kind of
process at work of that engagement that
you went through in both the writing and
in the communication of it the movie so
how did you feel about the movie oh I
loved it I think it's a great adaptation
it's a really true it's really true to
the novel which is rarer in movies
usually there's usually there's just
wild liberties taken this is just a very
faithful adaptation they had to take
some stuff out there to take a bunch of
subplots out but if they hadn't it'd be
like a six-hour movie so I mean you have
to they have to trim stuff out but the
things they removed are the things that
if they left it up to me I would remove
just to be clear here yeah I mean well
know that I would remove you know to
trim it down but people often ask Oh
what was your involvement in the movie
well my only job on the film was to cash
the check but it's basically the
contract which was 34 pages long and
needed to be notarized and signed in
four places basically boiled down to
we'll give you this much money for the
movie rights you get to attend the
premiere that is that is what happens to
writers in Hamlet the world I having
worked on a bunch of films I know but
they chose to involve me which was
really nice through Godard who wrote the
screenplay he was on the phone to me
almost every day when he was writing it
getting my feedback and then once they
started filming I would get these
questions filtered down from Ridley that
were interesting because I was like oh I
like the questions he's asking like it's
like hey can we show mark pouring
hydrazine from one container to another
out on the surface of Mars and I'm like
no the pressure of Mars is so low that
the hydrazine would just boil off he's
like alright then we won't do that I'm
like oh I effected that
but that's very rare ya know that both
to be involved in the the actual
production and to have the director
asking you questions like that
and you know I think it's part of why it
does sing on the screen I must say it
feels that way it I think it's a great
adaptation and and Damon absolutely
nailed the character Watney I mean he's
just exactly the way I imagined that me
too I just feels just exactly right yeah
I mean it's perfect well you know Stuart
and I had the experience of helping with
another novel of another friend daniel
suarez and getting it published through
a similar kind of story and then working
on the damon for those of you don't
remember and and we worked on the movie
script and it sucked because it was
really you couldn't actually translate
it well to this very complicated
complicated story that's why I'm so
admiring of how it actually turned out
the translation for the book to the
screen okay not for the fanboy stuff all
right I'll get well there'll be more of
that when they start if there are
important questions you have Andy
address but now let's get down to the
future getting to Mars
alright so why don't you start us on our
voyage how are we gonna get there well
I'm glad you asked so first thing you
need to understand is that when I wrote
the Martian the Ares mission profile as
is depicted in the book I I did that
specifically to be entertaining not
necessarily to be accurate I mean I
tried I wanted scientific accuracy as
much as possible but I also did things
to tug at your nostalgia heartstrings
and make it feel kind of like the Apollo
era and and to give you that that that
kind of feeling of yeah yeah kick ass in
reality I think the first manned mission
to Mars is going to be a large
international effort it's gonna be
organizationally similar to the
International Space Station it's not
just going to be the NASA show and I
think it'll probably be NASA ISA Ross
cosmos probably the Indian choice agency
by then what JAXA and also I would love
for it to include the Chinese we
cooperated with the Soviets in space in
the middle of the Cold War surely we can
cooperate with the Chinese now I mean so
I don't know why that distinction exists
Mao is still alive don't you know ya
little red book so but the technical
challenges of getting to Mars are very
significant Mars everybody knows Mars is
far away but I know a lot of people
don't really understand that the the
significance of the distance if you were
on a football field if you were at one
goalpost and Mars were at the other
goalpost the moon would be about three
or four centimeters in front of you like
that that is the scale and and we know
it's hard to get to the moon right so
now scale that out first thing you need
to deal with is that the mental health
of the crew requires a large ship you
can't just send six people to Mars in a
van you know you can't just expect
people to sit around for months in a
tiny enclosed space they're going to
need a large internal area where they
can move around get away from each other
do stuff also it just takes a lot of
ship to support humans for such a length
of time so let's assume that our Mars
transfer craft is going to be about the
same mass as the International Space
Station
okay sort of what you showed in the film
is yeah it has a feel of that hermes is
a big heavy ship that goes back that you
know they use to get to Mars and back to
earth it never lands it never in a bit
in the book version it actually does
aerobraking at both mars and earth to
save on reactant mass but but it never
lands they have a part of the ship they
have the MDV Mars descent vehicle so it
goes to Mars it comes goes into Mars
orbit then the MDV breaks off and lands
and then on the surface waiting for them
is the nav Mars ascent vehicle which
spent the last several months making
fuel out of the Martian the Martian
atmosphere and then that it's only job
is to get them back up to the main ship
and then the main ship takes them home
so you don't need to land this behemoth
on the ground but let's say that your
ship plus your MDV weighs about the same
as the International Space Station okay
to get to Mars even through a
traditional chemical propellant which is
you just you burn a big ol rocket and go
there the best time to do that there is
a specific launch window called a
Hohmann transfer window that is the
lowest M
of energy necessary to get to Mars from
Earth and that requires 5.7 kilometers a
second of total Delta V in other words
you have to change the velocity of your
ship a total of five thousand seven
hundred meters per second and so that
includes like front from low-earth orbit
to get to low Mars orbit so you have to
accelerate to get new on transfer orbit
then you have to accelerate again to
follow into Mars orbit okay to get that
with the best chemical propellant we
have which turns out to just be hydrogen
and oxygen Burnet that is that is the
very that's the best specific impulse
which basically is a measure of how
efficient fuel is at changing the
velocity of a ship to get that you would
need to have almost ten times the mass
of the ship in fuel so that means the
International Space Station which weighs
three hundred and eighty-five thousand
kilograms would need about three million
kilograms of fuel all right so let's
remember that now let's talk about how
much it costs to put things into orbit
all right let's say they use the SLS the
the Space Launch System which is going
to cost twenty billion dollars and it'll
be capable of putting a hundred and
fifty thousand kilograms into orbit how
much will it cost to put three million
kilograms into orbit well just to put
the ISS into orbit would cause this is
ignoring all of the other costs just
putting the mass of the ship itself not
the fuel just the mass of the ship
itself into orbit is about 51 billion
dollars putting the mass of all the fuel
into orbit and the ship gets you up to
about 500 billion dollars I mean we
could have a war with that much money
half a war the way we do yeah I mean we
could have a good sized war I mean with
that much money we don't want to be
wasting it on that so that is really bad
now the next thing to consider is okay
what about the better price to Elio
let's talk about the the Falcon 9 which
is the cheapest way the SpaceX Falcon 9
is currently the cheapest way to get
stuff into orbit there's more stuff
coming in the future but Falcon 9 is is
the cheapest right now it ends up
costing about 4,100 bucks
per kilogramme to get things into elio
which means putting the station into
orbit would cost about 1.5 billion so 15
billion to put it plus the fuel for Mars
Singh okay that's getting a bit more
reasonable with the Falcon Heavy it
drops down to about half of that the
Falcon Heavy has not been tested yet but
they estimate that it's going to be
about half the price so it's going down
and down but this is still very
expensive the problem is doing this
Hohmann transfer ellipse means you're on
your way to Mars and that's it you are
going to Mars by god and if something
goes wrong well you better fix it or
you're gonna die
you have no abort option you have
nothing you're going to Mars and that's
it and then if you have a problem on
Mars well tough [ __ ] because you're
gonna be on Mars for about 20 months
before the Hohmann transfer ellipse
window to go home
happens and so you are absolutely stuck
there which is why I and a lot of other
people think that traditional chemical
propulsion is not the way to go that the
solution is ion engines what I own
engines do is they take highly chao-li
charged particles well first they charge
them and then they spit them out the
back of the ship really really fast so
they use argon usually and you're
spewing art on out the back of the ship
you need a lot of energy to do this but
you don't need anywhere near as much
reactant mass as the oxygen hydrogen
fuel so you end up only needing 1.5
times your ship's mass of argon so
instead of having three million
kilograms of fuel you're gonna have
about 150 aren't sorry you're gonna have
about 500,000 kilograms of mass of argon
that and you're gonna need a reactor to
power it because ain't no way you're
getting that much power out of out of
sales out of sorry solar cells so that
means you need a nuclear reactor aboard
your ship that means you need to deal
with the political issues of convincing
people that it's okay to put a nuclear
reactor on your spaceship in orbit
around Earth or you could be the
Russians and not care
which is great a foot nuclear power
plants in space we have or we have
indeed but it's what we both Bennett
we've done it and the Soviets did it
okay so let's say you do that we've also
tested the ion engine wait yes the ion
engine this is not speculative
technology these are real things they
are used on real probes I think the dawn
don't used it so this is this is real
technology this isn't just made-up stuff
they would need to be scaled away ah but
it's real now that I approve he approved
I approve it's the right answer these if
we have one vote for ion it
all right now that oh we have one we
have yeah now they're even yeah all
right next thing you need to deal with
is it oh by the way within the context
of the book I calculated all the orbital
trajectories III gave Hermes the ion
engines that capable of accelerating at
two millimeters per second per second
which is about this fast but for a long
time but notice it's going faster now
and you do that for months and months
and months you're hauling ass and so
what ultimately happens is you can get
to Mars under the trajectory I
calculated in 124 days the Hohmann
transfer lives takes about two hundred
and fifty four days so in other words
doing ion engines takes four months
Hohmann transfer lifts takes eight so
you get to Mars faster also you can
abort
you can go [ __ ] and go back home because
you're constantly accelerating so you
turn around it well it's not as simple
as turn around and you probably have to
go around the Sun and there's all sorts
of complicated crap but you're not
locked into this into this mode and you
can abort early when you're at Mars and
you don't need to stay on Mars for 20
months you can stay there for 31 Souls
or whatever your desired mission
duration like this it gives you so many
abort options it's so much safe what's a
soul a soul is one Martian day the time
it takes Mars to rotate once on its axis
which by cosmic coincidence happens to
be very very close to Earth day length a
soul on Mars is is 24 hours and 39
minutes so it's just a little bit longer
whereas meanwhile a soul on Venus is
about like 214 days so you know planet's
gonna plan it so the next thing you need
to deal with is the long-term effects of
zero-g now weightlessness is bad for the
human body
we've spent a couple of billion years
evolving in an environment that has 1g
of acceleration downward at all times
and our bodies rely on that for a number
of things long-term effects of zero-g
include bone degradation osteoporosis
muscle degeneration weakness of the
heart macular degeneration in the eyes
which can eventually lead to blindness
and they're just now discovering immune
response issues it screws with the
immune system in some way that they're
not really sure they understand the
current way to deal with it and the way
they experiment with it right now Scott
Kelly is up on ISS doing a full year in
space had to test him versus his twin
Mark Kelly who was on the ground and
they so they can compare the two and
would they just have them doing a rigid
exercise program now any any doctor can
tell you that that exercise program
reduces but does not eliminate the bone
loss issue reduces but does not
eliminate muscle weakness issues keeps
your heart pretty healthy actually you
can pretty much completely cancel the
problems with your heart but it doesn't
do anything against the macular
degeneration in your eyes spending long
periods of time in zero-g does permanent
damage to your eyes how important is
your vision to you probably pretty
important and so I believe strongly and
many disagree that the best way to solve
all this is not to let them be in zero-g
but make a ship that spins so they have
centripetal force serving as gravity so
now their bodies are having the same
force exerted on them as they would on
earth or maybe you just have it be one
Martian gravity which is about point
four of Earth's gravity and that takes
care of all the problems they don't need
to spend you know a third of their day
dealing with exercise they can do other
experiments on the trip they don't need
to lose their vision they don't have any
of these problems that does mean however
you need to make a spaceship that is
capable of spinning and maintaining that
force constant
no need for this entire time that's a
lot of force fortunately we have about
10,000 years of experience in how to
build things that don't fall down in 1g
of force
it's called architecture okay we've
worked this out so that's the next thing
long-term effects of zero-g so we've got
an ion drive the spinning spinning
spinning it's called a spinny thingy is
being the technical sitting okay okay
now on to the very biggest problem a
problem that no one has solved radiation
radiation in space is a big problem here
on earth were protected from radiation
by our magnetosphere which deflects most
of the radiation away from the planet
and what little does get through gets
blocked by a relatively thick atmosphere
on the way to Mars you have neither of
those protect when you're in low-earth
orbit you're still protected by the
magnetosphere our astronauts on ISS are
safe within Earth's magnetic shield but
once you leave Earth leave Earth orbit
you're on your own and there's two kinds
of radiation you need to deal with one
of them is solar radiation which are
rapidly moving particles coming off of
the Sun because it spews a lot of crap
out the other thing it's called GCRs
which stands for galactic cosmic rays
which is a horrible misnomer because
they're not cosmic rays they're highly
to their high velocity particles
traveling it at relativistic speeds are
going very very fast or it doesn't have
this problem it just gets hit by they
get knocked out of the way or absorbed
in the atmosphere if you're out in space
you're gonna get bombarded with this
stuff and you're going to get if you
were to go to Mars over the course of
your trip to Mars your stay on Mars and
then you return to Earth you would get
many many lifetime's worth of your safe
dosage of radiation during that time you
absolutely would get cancer I mean you
can virtually guarantee it now one
rather in my opinion reckless idea is
that they've had the idea of saying like
well let's just send old people
the idea how many over 65 will you know
right yeah okay that is an idea they
said what let's say let's make 50 the
minimum age because the idea is that
like getting that much radiation
dramatically increases the odds that
you're going to get cancer in 40 or 50
years but the 50 year olds are like
bring it right that's one that's one
option I think that's not a good option
I don't I don't think so you get cancer
is a good solution I think a better
solution unfortunately is that you we
need to have some sort of radiation
shielding problem is there there is
unlike my book which has magical thin
flexible total radiation shielding
there's no such thing like that in real
life just to block the to block the
radiation in space just out out in inner
interplanetary space you would need 2
centimeters of lead or 10 centimeters of
water or a full meter of rock so that
starts to make your ship pretty heavy
and they don't have a good solution for
that one possible solution they've
they've thought of is say like okay well
the crews going to need a water supply
let's store it in the hull and we'll
have like 10 centimeters of water in the
hull and then we'll have as they
generate sewage they will be you know
you're gonna want to keep those things
separate but you'll ultimately replace
your water supply with a protective
layer of [ __ ] and you'll be safe from
radiation because of that problem is
that's like way more water than you
would normally need to send on a mission
even of that duration and so it's just
mass mass mass and there isn't really a
good solution to this yet so it's what
would be awesome is if if material
scientists could find a way to make a
lighter radiation shielding and there
has been some success in that area
alternating strips of like plastic and
metal have proven to be more effective
than the plastic or the metal on their
own because of things I won't pretend to
understand but that that is a serious
issue I think you do go with the proton
with the ice I I think the ice is the
solution yeah you capsulate the vehicle
in a big ball of ice basically you can
do that on the other thing is if you if
you build
transfer ship out of a near-earth
asteroid right the idea is you just find
something that's like a bit Rock and
then build your you know your crew
habitat inside of it and then move the
whole rock of course that means you got
to move the rock gets a lot of mass yeah
but at least you don't have to move the
rock up from Earth which is where the
real expense come you to collect your
ice on the moon well then you only have
to lift it up off of the moon well it's
also pretty easy to I mean you can also
find rocks on the moon here and there
but so radiation is a serious issue it's
actually a bigger problem during the
transit to Mars than it is on the planet
itself
now Mars has practically no magnetic
field so it's not protecting you from
radiation and it has a really really
thin atmosphere so that's also not
protecting you from radiation but when
you're on Mars half of the universe is
on the other side of Mars from you and
that protects you from radiation there's
nothing like a few thousand kilograms of
planet to stop a galactic particle so
you actually get about half the dose
while you're on the surface of Mars
because Mars itself protects you now the
next thing is just a side note the nav
making your own fuel well it's pretty
cool there's a thing called the savatya
reaction that takes if you have carbon
dioxide and hydrogen you can put them
together to make methane and water and
energy okay
all of these things are in ridiculously
huge abundance on Mars the atmosphere is
ninety-six percent carbon dioxide so you
have a virtually infinite supply of that
the ground thanks to curiosity okay so
in my book Mark has to do all sorts of
crazy stuff to make water yes the guy he
takes hydrazine he reduces it he you
know Liberty it's the hydrogen then he
burns I George and blows himself up a
little bit and then he gets hurt yeah
and it's all that stuff like that so
after I wrote the book and it was
already in print curiosity landed on
Mars went scoop there's a shitload of
water in the soil so all you really
needed to do was bring dirt inside and
heat it up turns out for every cubic
meter of Martian soil there's 35 liters
of water it's a huge amount of water
available all over the surface of Mars
so that gets you water which is made of
hydrogen and oxygen so you electrolyze
that you get the hydrogen now you got
the carbon diet
side you got energy either from a solar
cell or from a RTG or some other energy
source so you can perform the Sabatier
reaction and the end result is you get a
bunch of methane and water which you can
then take apart to refeed the reaction
but the point is you end up with methane
which is ch4 and a bunch of Elemental
oxygen because you've been electrolyzing
the water methane and oxygen that's
rocket fuel
there was a project at NASA called
Morpheus where they tested this where
they tested a controlled launch and a
controlled rocket engine that that burns
methane and oxygen and it worked great
methane just natural gas it's basically
a natural gas rocket yep it's discovery
water is actually quite significant huge
changes the game in a big way completely
changes the game because it it is now
possible to make as much rocket fuel as
you want on the surface Mars people
often miss people often mistake what the
significance of water on Mars are people
are like oh there's water that means we
can go there and drink it's like you are
already gonna drink alright you know you
could just send up you can send like you
know 20 kilograms of water per person to
Mars and you can have a water
reclamation system that deals with it
what water to drink is not the issue
hydrogen is the issue and hydrogen
allows you to make rocket fuel so that's
the cool thing so you're at you you the
kind of solution to all of this is you
make a ship in orbit then you use ion
propulsion to send it to Mars then you
have an M DV that lands you have an M a
V that has spent the last few months
using stuff on Mars to make rocket fuel
you do your surface mission you get back
in the nav you go back up to your ship
use its ion engines to come home and
you're set that's how you that's that
that's how we do our first manned
mission to Mars now the question is why
send people to Mars at all good question
why send people to Mars at all I'm glad
you asked that the short answer is you
shouldn't not right now because the
problem is we have no need to send
people to Mars if your objective is
gathering science right now yes an
astronaut would be way the hell more
efficient and more effective than any
robot we send curiosity can move a few
meters a day an astronaut Andy B
suit could run all over the place an
astronaut can glance this way and that
and figure out oh that's the rock I want
to go look at that one I don't if you
just want science and astronauts way
better than a robot right now but if you
give me fifty 1 billion dollars I bet
you I can make you a robot that's as
effective as an astronaut
ok and nobody dies if I [ __ ] up
so yeah way you can it becomes cheaper
to send you don't need to bring it back
and radiation is less you don't care
about radiation you can make it
radiation shield air or just immune to
radiation so if you're just attempting
to gather information about Mars you
shouldn't be considering sending people
there the reason you send people to Mars
is to figure out how to send people to
Mars because in the long term especially
for an organization like the long now
you're gonna want to back up the human
race by putting some of them on another
planet and as long as we're all on one
planet we have a non-trivial chance of
extinction it could be a war it could be
a disease it could be an astronomical
event but if we're on two planets that
drops down to virtually zero 25 years as
a software engineer has taught me the
importance of backing up your data so
the reason to send people to Mars is to
figure out how to send people to Mars
and so that we can eventually colonize
it now the the one remaining obvious
question well before you go into the
next one ok so last week I actually was
on a panel in London or two weeks ago
with Martin Rees the astronomer royal of
Britain who holds one of the great jobs
he held the Isaac Newton chair at
Cambridge of his great title right so I
asked so we debated this question he
believes it's all robots right we don't
really need to send people that the
robots are gonna get smart enough fast
enough and even if they're maybe they're
human controlled robots they're aliens
you know basically Waldo's of one sort
another but inevitably his view is that
the that it's a very long time before we
ever really need humans again in space
that the Mandara is over my answer to
him was it's not about back up though it
is that it's about basically the human
spirit it's a base you know this is we
want to go out into the galaxy we want
to go into the universe we have always
you know spread ourselves around the
planet and given the opportunity in the
technology we want
to go into space and we will find a way
it's why Branson's going it's ye lime
Elon Musk is going and so on the
practical consequences I think are quite
secondary to that real drive to explore
and to venture outwards
I think you're right and but before we
can even consider colonizing a planet we
need to know how to make humans live on
it and also the economics of it need to
work out it needs to be something that
you you can emigrate to Mars by spending
your life savings to do it right now you
can't do that right so the the the the
purpose of putting humans on Mars is to
find out if how to put humans on Mars
now the next question last bit I was
going to say was why not colonize the
moon it's so much closer it's so much
easier it's quick to get to it can be
somewhat earth dependent while you're
initially setting up the colony unlike
colony on Mars which has to be
completely self-sufficient you could
work your way slowly to self-sufficiency
it's cheaper yeah you can you can go
like crap this guy needs medical
attention it takes him like four days to
get back to earth you know that's that's
what it took an Apollo capsule right so
why why colonize Mars and not earth long
because Mars has everything necessary
for life to keep getting bigger if you
imagine you've got humans you have food
you're generating your own food in this
eventual colony you need to have a
biosphere there's a certain biomass and
that does not increase unless you're
gathering elements from outside the
system in other words if you had a lunar
colony and you had a thousand people on
it and enough crops to support a
thousand people and everything's run
perfectly you'd have stability but how
do you get bigger how do you grow
another how do you grow another field of
wheat fine you make another dome out of
like local materials there's plenty of
aluminium and stuff like that there's
plenty of oxygen on the moon whatever
you make another dome where do you get
the carbon that ultimately makes that
new field of wheat there's no carbon on
the moon or not enough not enough to
matter where do you get the nitrogen
which is also critical there's none of
that and where do you get the hydrogen
there's a little of that there's water
on the moon but it would be like oil on
earth
it's rare and difficult and you'd have
to go you'd have to go through hardship
and and difficulty to go get it and so
out of the four critical elements of
life carbon hydrogen oxygen and nitrogen
there's only one of them in abundance on
the moon and that's oxygen and there's
tons of oxygen caught up in the oxidized
materials on the moon Mars has all four
of those in virtually infinite supply
the atmosphere is carbon dioxide so
that's two of them two percent of the
atmosphere is nitrogen and if the andif
that's several billion tons isn't enough
there are nitrates already in the soil
and then finally so 2h hydrogen there's
water there's tons and tons of water so
that shown the four things that you need
for life are all over Mars so if you had
a Mars colony and a Mar Anna and a
biosphere inside your little Mars base
you could make a new dome and say like
well we need we need to add more carbon
dioxide to the system to so that this
new wheat field can breathe get some
carbon dioxide we need to add water to
the system for this increased biomass
get some water
we need more nitrates get some nitrogen
everything's right there on Mars so
that's why you call it as Mars and not
the moon
so just to finish up before you throw it
open for questions so you've thought
really pretty thoroughly about this you
thought about it little elements in in
the book there's a lot of debate about
ok should we can we what will cost how
to organize and so on let's assume the
politics are all taken care of for a
moment and thinking about both the
financial and technical challenges and
actually pulling off what you've said if
we were starting today when do you think
realistically it would be plausible to
actually put an expedition on the moon
not yet a colony just pretty close to
what was in the book and close to the
film on Mars Mars moon I'm in Mars sorry
Isle I guess around 2050 nASA says the
NASA has it in mind to get people you
know like boots on Mars around 2035 I
have no doubt that they could given
enough funding I just don't think that
much funding is realistic so I'm gonna
guess around 2050 also I think Mars
missions aren't gonna look the way we
think they are
I think the first manned mission to Mars
is really going to be more like Apollo
ten I think you're gonna see we're gonna
litter Mars with robots and then we're
gonna send people to live in orbit
around Mars and so now we have a zero
latency connection between human brains
and robots on the surface so they can
remote control unlike RC cars and just
do what okay I'm gonna go over there Oh
that rocks cool I'm gonna go over there
as opposed to this four to 20-minute
communication latency we have with our
probes right now because that's what's
really slowing things down the lack of a
human brain on scene but just putting
humans in orbit around Mars it's a hell
of a lot easier than landing them on the
surface and getting them back up so III
roughly agree with your time frame I
think that is plausible given both the
financial and kind of political issues
of actually putting together that I
don't see any inherently technologically
insuperable problems like you I think
the radiation issue that is the biggest
one yet it's something we didn't know at
the beginning of the Space Age really
that that would be the biggest barrier
here's a fun fact
the astronauts you may be wondering well
wait what about the what about the
Apollo astronauts who we sent outside of
her atmosphere they got blasted with
radiation that's just how it was but
they were they weren't out for very long
they were out for like eleven days or
something like that and during that time
they got about a hundred x-rays worth of
radiation about the same as getting a
hundred x-rays and almost all of them
developed cataracts which is one of the
one of the first one of the your eyes
are very sensitive to radiation and so
you get cataracts if you get exposed to
radiation and here's another fun thing
between Apollo 11 and Apollo 12 during
that six-month window there was a huge
solar radiation event and if there had
been an Apollo mission in progress at
the time they almost certainly would
have died or aborted very fast or
aborted very quickly if they could have
yeah but that probably wouldn't have
been able to because it was dating it
would it was you know it was day on the
near side of the moon so they would have
been exposed as sunlight so they it was
just luck that they just happened to not
be doing a mission at the time that's
other elements of luck the people who
didn't realize it yeah it didn't happen
that almost did almost almost every
Apollo mission had some near near
catastrophe
when they landed on 11 they had like two
and a half seconds left of fuel well
yeah and their computer kept crashing
yeah exactly it was all manual anyway
okay so now we're before we get to get
into questions one of the things that
happened subsequently to the book coming
out and quite recently good friend over
here John gage formerly of Sun
Microsystems one of the earliest people
and a friend of many of ours got so
motivated by the book they decided this
is worthy of an educational curriculum
decompose the book would you flash your
thing got it up here okay page after
page of every problem solution how to
take this book and turn it into one of
the great curricula that students can
learn John gage at gmail write to John
and you will get this doc send pictures
fun pictures sending a lot of cat
pictures anyway my point is there is a
great opportunity to expand this and
there's going to be a Scholastic version
of the book free of [ __ ] and [ __ ]
words like that so having said that we
now have the convergent pieces to
inspire science as well okay questions
comments from the floor right over here
we'd like to have you use a mic if you
don't mind because we want to have it
for the for our viewers of the viewers
at home so one of the things so the book
is widely acclaimed for being a science
fiction book about science one of things
I think is interesting is not just about
science but it's also about engineering
it's about problem solving and so I was
wondering it was that and I think that's
both one of the things that makes a lot
of frankly nerds and engineers like it
it's one thing it's one of the things
that as a lot of attention to the book
but I also think it's one of the things
that make it makes
great was that deliberate on your part
or you just you were just an engineer
doing your engineer thing and you solve
problems
yeah the latter I'm just I like problem
solving and I like stories related to
problem solving and so that's just kind
of how it came out like right here so
there's a story called the Martian way
by Isaac Asimov where you which you've
not read I I maybe have tell me that
anyway
he talks about like ones people with
humans with their capacity to to adapt
once you are used to Mars and confined
spaces and whatnot you are able to
survive a lot longer and a lot more
confined spaces and this thing okay you
did you think about people adapting to
adapting to the environment you're
talking about for colonization or you
talked about in the book
Oh in the book well I think Asimov was
talking about people who grew up in the
in that environment and in the book it's
just a manned mission so these people
all grew up on earth so it wouldn't
affect them over here so we got a
question from Wade so thanks everybody
listening on the live stream there's a
question from the folks out there can
you expand a little bit more on the
architecture that's required for a
spinning ship and would it be able to
generate 1g continuously yes so a
spinning ship is one of the main
concepts is you don't need to make a
giant like like wheel in space or thirst
wheels like yeah you don't need to make
one of those giant things hugely massive
or also like the way Hermes is presented
in the movie is a lot of math all you
would need would be two segments of the
ship that are approximately equal mass
connected by a long cable and then you
what's that bolo it's a bolo yeah it's a
space bolo and it's just spinning and
you could you could have it be a hundred
meters apart it's just a cable you know
want to make sure that cable doesn't
break but and then you started spinning
and then that will provide centripetal
force in the same way that you can you
know take a bucket full of water and do
this and the water won't come out
toppy if you do it fast enough and it
would maintain whatever gravity you
wanted probably the best idea would be
to have it provide point for G's of
gravity during the astronauts trip to
Mars so that they are used to that
gravity and comfortable with it by the
time they get there and then for the
trip back they start at point four G's
and then very slowly increase it during
the many month trip back to 1g so that
they're comfortable once they're back on
earth so we've got a question here here
and then we'll take you back there okay
so SpaceX has announced their plans for
the MCT for the what for the Mars
colonial transport and that is seems
kind of count Kinnear is the microphone
working okay so the SpaceX MCT seems
pretty different from the suggestions
that you made so they're talking about
using rocket fuel engines talking about
main missions to Mars by mid 2020s have
you spent much time thinking about kind
of the differences in design or how
SpaceX is tackling the problem
differently than what you've suggested I
haven't looked into the the MCT at all
I'm first PT transport thank you yeah I
haven't looked into that at all with
SpaceX I'm much more interested in their
their actual like shorter term plans not
not by highly speculative stuff so I'm
much more impressed by the Falcon Heavy
that's what I'm really waiting for I
honestly believe that the true the the
true path forward for space travel and
interplanetary travel is by driving down
the cost to Elio if you can drive the
price down Elio low-earth orbit thank
you yes driving down the price to
low-earth orbit if you can get the price
down much further than it is right now
then everything starts to become
cost-effective if it only costs only if
it only costs like 10 billion dollars to
do a manned mission to Mars we do it
absolutely the government beep yeah sure
yeah but it doesn't cost 10 billion it
costs a lot more and the reason for that
is the vast majority of the money spent
is getting things from Earth's surface
into low-earth orbit now the reason for
that is because well imagine how
expensive it would be to fly from New
York to London if you threw the plane
away after you flew
because that's what we do right now so
you know that's why SpaceX is working on
you know reusable Rock everybody's
working on reusable rockets not just
like Space Shuttle style where 90% of
the math gets thrown away and it's a big
nest it's like they want to land the
rocket back up and they let it succeeded
in that but it's awesome that they're
trying yeah like I mean III I agree with
you i think the challenge of getting
there by 20 or 2020 2025 2030 is
actually pretty unrealistic like you I
think that the challenge low Earth orbit
is exactly right and that they have
basically got that right
I will eventually Ilan you know Ilan's
great quote I hope to die on Mars but
not on impact Yeah right right right you
know next question first thank you so
much for writing this I think it's
gotten a lot of people excited about
these very difficult problems wondering
one if you had a chance to play the game
Kerbal space program I I haven't played
it but I know all about it
what a cool space program it's a game
about getting things into orbit safely
and getting them back yeah it's a it's a
it's an orbital physics simulator and
you can do all that you can build your
ships and there's a lot of options thing
is I don't want to manually control a
ship I just yeah and then to like
anything else out there that you're
seeing that is gonna get the next
generation of kids excited about solving
these problems anything that's exciting
you now that's on the horizon I really
think we're on the cusp of being able to
explore much deeper into the solar
system because of ion engines I think
that's the that's the technology that's
in progress right now that's that's
gonna be the biggest game-changer fact
if somebody would pass the mic way back
there and Mike do we have any more on
line yet sure okay good yeah why don't
we pass that and give us a would I ever
do a sequel to Martian I get asked that
right yeah so no basically there's no
there's there's no idea there if I ever
get an idea for a sequel the Martian
believe me I'll get right on it I love
writing Watney I love all the characters
and it was a fun book to write but it's
just there's a you know what you know oh
my god I'm on the sofa and I'm out of
beer and the store has closed how do I
survive it's like unless unless you put
Watney in trouble again yeah that's a
very exciting yeah he's on he's on board
unless you put Watney in trouble again
it's not that exciting if you put Watney
in trouble again
it's very implausible and it's like oh
can you believe this guy's the jovian so
that titanium titanium
yeah the Venusian yeah and so you end up
it ends up either being implausibly
unlikely or no longer focused on Watney
I mean you know a lot of people said
like oh okay well you know he could be
on the ground helping someone else in
space I'm like well then the person
who's in trouble is the one who's more
interesting not him on the ground and
then you'd say like okay well why don't
you cover the trip home from Mars where
they're on a ship that's way past its
maintenance aid there could be stuff
like that and it'd be just kind of like
you know he's not he's not by himself on
Mars
he's with a competent skilled crew of
five other people he's not isolated he
has contact with Mission Control
he's on a ship that's actually designed
to last for five entire missions it's
just there's not enough story there no
back there and then we've got a couple
more questions up here thanks I enjoyed
the book enjoyed the movie enjoy the
lecture and I say that not to be a
fanboy but to say to preface what might
sound otherwise like a somewhat
disrespectful question we like questions
like that go for it your use of the
in-situ propellant propulsion the fully
fueled Mars ascent vehicle the tethered
bolo at least in your later comments the
Mars versus moon all this is from Mars
direct
super and as you well know right well
not all much yeah
well all of it was in it may what maybe
wasn't original to it but anyway and the
SpaceX mission architectures to Mars are
also based on that yet you reject well
let me say that you embrace certain
things that Mars direct rejects you
embrace space nuclear power ion engines
and Mars in 50 years or 40 years from
present I'm and the deadly radiation
Bugaboo so I'm kind of wondering how you
chose to accept certain things and
reject other things from a mission
architecture that summary argue to get
us to Mars in the very near future
sure so Mars Mike back up please so Mars
direct is a very is is what's invented
in the 1980s and it was the most
advanced and generally accepted method
for a good way to get to Mars as of the
technology that was available in the
1980s it's been about 30 years since
then as Marty McFly can tell you and a
lot of the technology is out of date and
I've also never agreed with the notion
of having the entire return craft be on
the surface of Mars I think that was
sort of a ludicrous idea even in the
1980s so having having a craft in orbit
and then having an ascent vehicle go to
that craft and then have that craft come
home that's that's a must agree having
nuclear the the reason that Mars direct
doesn't use nuclear power or at least
didn't when it was originally envisioned
is because we didn't have plausible we
didn't have any plausible reason to
believe that ion engines could be as
effective as they actually are back when
Zubrin came up with Mars direct so
basically all my idea is is take Mars
direct and update it for stuff that's
been invented over the last thirty years
good answer take a question here Garrett
and you get the last question thank you
I thank you so much for your
contribution to popular culture you're
welcome to an amazing
I have two questions one is that aren't
things that are it's one thing to wear a
big red blanket when you go to the
dental office but when you're in space
isn't everything irradiated including
this rocks and everything on the surface
of other planets good question the
second question is in the beginning of
your astoundingly accurate and
scientific lecture you said that we were
going to rely on a whole bunch of
different government entities to propel
us into aerospace but I'm wondering what
your thoughts are on commercial space
and if the advancement of technology as
it seems is like makes every makes five
years into 2.5 years
shouldn't we be in on Mars a lot sooner
than then you say okay good questions so
a loss to thrive what was the first
question irradiation radio yeah Walt
okay ship itself become radioactive not
really so the thing is the things that
block radiation tend to not become
radioactive and also if you go to a
planet it's not like the rocks on the
planet are radioactive if you put a big
lump of metal out on the surface of the
planet and left it there it would slowly
gain some radiation but it's not like
it's being bombarded with a nuclear bomb
amount of radiation it's just way more
than is safe for humans to hang around
in for months and months so the if if
you had radiation shielding in your base
you wouldn't have any problem going out
for like evey A's in unshielded EBA
suits stuff like that so if your total
amount of time spent outside of
radiation shielding is a few hours it
would be fine so it's not like you're
standing next to an unshielded reactor
core it's not it's not that level so in
terms of commercial space travel I
definitely do believe that commercial is
the way forward I also believe that the
first manned mission to Mars will
include like all that stuff that we have
to put into orbit I think it'll be
contracted so I think that commercial
space flight like SpaceX and and and
other competitors as long as Bigelow as
long as there are competitors will drive
the price of putting mass into
down and so when we see that first you
know big manned mission to Mars it's
gonna be like they're gonna contract out
the heavy lifting to these to these
companies and then the man the actual
astronauts will go up on some
government-run rocket but if you if you
own a widget factory you don't then
invent trucks to transport widgets
around the company in the country you
you hire a trucking company to transport
the widgets around the country and I
think that's that's so commercial space
flight the space travel is gonna play a
huge role in it right now however the
government is the only customer for the
most part the only customer of Space
Flight there are private entities that
need to have satellites in orbital yeah
but by far the major money comes from
the government and as long as there's no
like competition as long as as long as
the only entities buying it are not
necessarily fiscally responsible it's
not gonna be as much of pressure to
drive the cost down
xander where are you can we take two
more quick questions okay so Garrett you
get to ask you a question and you get to
ask you a question and then we'll do the
answer so I think we're all very
impressed by how realistic it all the
story what are the three things in it
that you where you got it wrong not
because of them well maybe because of a
mistake but for artistic reasons
therefore whatever what are the most
unrealistic and let's get the other
question okay well I'll get to that and
but we're gonna get the other question
first I guess yep here's the mic what's
your opinion on the importance of an
justification of the cost of sterilizing
any kind of equipment before it goes on
to Mars okay note that a great question
okay suppose yours
so the three biggest screw-ups in the
book are intentional and otherwise our
number one the sandstorm in the
beginning is by far the least physically
accurate thing in the book
Mars's atmosphere is about one-half of
one percent the density of Earth's
atmosphere so while they do get a
hundred and fifty kilometer an hour
winds the inertia behind them is very
very weak and so it would have a
difficult time knocking over a piece of
paper let alone a twenty seven ton
ascent vehicle so it would feel like I
mean it would feel like that it's just
so and I knew that at the time and I had
a different I had a different disaster
in mind that was physically accurate
where they're doing an MA V engine tests
and there's an explosion and all that
happens but it just wasn't as cool and
it was a man versus nature story I
wanted nature to get the first punch in
so I was deliberately inaccurate at the
time most people didn't know that
Martian sand storms were that weak now
that the Martian has come out everybody
knows so I have inadvertently educated
the world on the strength of Martian
sandstorms I feel good about that
actually very good as a teaching role
yeah on number two the radiation I just
completely hand waved it away within the
context of the Martian they have a thin
light flexible radiation shielding that
just surrounds all of their like it the
hab as radiation shielded the Hermes as
radiation shielded the Rovers or
radiation shielded so he has no problems
with radiation at all it's just I
mention it so it's not like an oversight
but it's it's super tech that is
inconsistent with the rest of the story
which is all real tech the third thing
it's a tie between a few things stuff
that there's a whole category of things
that have been discovered since I I
published the book that have been
validated things in the book like
finding so much water in the soil that
happened later the University of Arizona
who controls the high rise instrument on
Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter decided to
take an extremely detailed photo of the
Ares three landing site because I say
the exact coordinates in the book so
they they take like well let's see
what's there I know I guess doesn't look
anything like he described
and yeah come on we're yeah and then the
one other thing it's minor but the plis
which stands for portable life support
system it's the backpack part of a
spacesuit modern-day places-- NASA is
just in the past few years invented a
method of sorting out the co2 without
expendable filters so just co2
separation would have been a non-issue
for him indefinitely interesting answers
okay and never externalism why this is
interesting ok the planetary protection
is is a policy in place the idea is we
need to sterilize anything we send to
Mars make sure that everything is dead
every little microbe or as much as much
as possible so that we don't infect Mars
with earth life for fear that some earth
life might be able to germinate on Mars
we don't even know if there's anything
on earth that can actually live and
thrive and reproduce on Mars but oh
anything on earth that can live on right
but it might be possible and we don't
want to infect Mars with invasive
bacteria or something like that just in
case there's actually life on Mars and
if there is earth life might subsume it
kind of like various psychological
disasters we've had over the years where
you know non-indigenous life is
introduced into an area and it just
completely displaces or ruins the
original ecosystem ok so that's the idea
behind planetary protection and the idea
is that they try to sterilize it I think
it's a big waste of time ok so that
that's my opinion
ok and I think and why is it a big waste
of time because I have a few reasons why
I think it's a big waste of time
first of all we have landed twelve
different things on Mars between us us
the US and the Soviets okay and the
earlier things that we landed on Mars
were either weekly weekly defended or oh
sorry weekly irradiated or cleared or
not at all like the Soviets didn't put
much effort into it at all
lip service if anything so if if Mars is
going to be infected by invasive earth
life it has already happened second off
Mars and Earth have been exchanging
material for billion
of years I have a Mars meteorite at home
it cost a lot of money but that's what I
do with my book my earnings so so I buy
a Mars ya meteor 5 so the two the two
planets have been exchanging have been
exchanging material for billions of
years and the the probes that we've sent
there have already and infected it now
let's let either one of two things is
true either earth life is a death
sentence to Mars and just means that
it's gonna completely invasively just
ruin whatever biosphere is there or it's
not and it might be just either
absolutely no effect or just a little
area of effect right around the probe
like a like a petri dish kind of thing
right so one of those things is true if
it ruins all of Mars then Mars is
already ruined it's done if it doesn't
then it doesn't okay then that means
that okay well here's a little area that
got ruined here's an area that got
ruined big deal big deal now we have
discovered the RSL's recurring slope
lineae on mars which are briny patches
of liquid water
okay flowing on the surface of mars and
it happens through a very complicated
process of water absorption and and
pressure build-up and then finally
flowing if there is life on Mars today
it will be in that water and now the
nearest RSL to curiosity which is an
active probe is about 50 kilometers away
curiosity could get there in about 200
days curiosity's life span is beyond
that so in other words if we made it an
opportunity curiosity could go look at
some liquid flowing water on Mars to
find out if there's anything living in
it but planetary protection won't let us
because they're afraid that curiosity
might have some microbes on it even
though curiosity underwent full
sterilization so I think it's a waste of
time Mike is there something you really
wanted to add
yes thank you Mars curiosity so some are
curious you were to me in thanking Andy
for what I don't know you but found a
thrilling evening thank you
thank you thank you sir yes yes oh yeah
you also get a challenge going from the
interval from thank you very much thank
you all of our speakers and thank you
Peter for hosting tonight I love
[Music]
you